it is very easy to become numb to media
bias these days so the ingram angle is
keeping track of the worst offenders of
the year
joining me now is curt slitter
townhall.com senior columnist and our
meet dylan ceo at the center for
american liberty and rnc national
committee woman for california you guys
let's begin with what the media said
about kyle rittenhouse
in wisconsin you have rittenhouse a
white teenager who crossed state lines
with an ar-15 style rifle he crossed
state lines with an ar-15
threw himself in the middle of all this
and started shooting people
but kurt there's this little thing about
how he actually did not cross state
lines with an ar-15
i love how they're stunned about all of
this that americans actually cross state
lines although he didn't uh that
americans actually have ar-15s which
they do i shot one myself this week and
uh how they're they're stunned stunned i
say
that that an american might defend
himself against for example a convicted
child rapist um
the media is a little bit out touch just
just a hair as the jury said
unequivocally
i mean herme they really slandered this
poor kid it was just uh disgusting what
they did to him
oh absolutely and that was just one of
the many lies that the media told
repeatedly and then they never went back
and corrected it so i don't know where
kyle goes to get his reputation back but
i suspect we're going to hear more about
that in coming months well hopefully he
sues the pants off of them and i think
you could probably offer some pretty
good advice on that so i also want to
turn to the virginia governor's race the
media says there's only one reason that
glenn younkin won watch
glenn younkin played the race card for a
reason because he knows it works on
certain white voters he did stoke white
grievance politics to mobilize the
republican base some republican
candidates are perfectly willing to use
race as a motivating factor for their
base
yeah hermita it obviously had nothing to
do with terry mcauliffe insulting
parents or the dems failing agenda
hermit
curt i lost the audio oh no worries for
me kurt what do you make of that uh yeah
obviously they're they're trying to
shift blame away from a terrible
candidate
well of course they are lisa look for
the left and it's minions in the media
uh racism is the swift swiss army knife
it's the answer to all your problems uh
you know
voters don't like you well the voters
are racist uh you're not able to get
your uh bills passed through congress uh
congress is racist uh no one loves you
you live alone and you eventually die
and you're eaten by your cats
racism everything's racism and it's all
ridiculous i think americans are getting
tired of it
i i think they are as well and i think
that's what we saw with the virginia
governor's race you know there's also
you know here's how msnbc rachel maddow
reacted when the cdc guidance didn't
quite fit her narrative anymore watch if
you are vaccinated it's okay to take off
your masks now indoors
and out
really
are you sure how sure are you
kurt how sure are you
well look there's
there's something for everybody to hate
with the cdc's mass guidance since
they've literally had every position
first we had oh don't wear a mask then
you have to wear one mask then you have
to wear two masks then no masks now you
have to wear a mask again now it's an
n95 mask who knows what it's going to be
tomorrow maybe it'll be an entire
plastic suit i don't know the fact is
the cdc has no credibility uh in that
way it's very similar to the media
yeah herme we've got you back now you
know what do you make about all this
flip-flopping from the cdc all these
different things we've heard from media
figures as well everyone's been all over
the map about pretty much everything
well the cdc
and the media have completely failed
here to provide a consistent message to
the american public for public health
reasons that would actually enable us to
protect ourselves against coven and i
think the inconsistencies and the
messaging and the flip-flopping have
really undermined american confidence
and that's very dangerous because this
isn't going to be the only health crisis
that we have and so i hope that the
media takes a long hard look at how they
have
distorted guidance they have condemned
people who have now come forward with
information that has now turned out to
be true and they have actually even
turned on the cdc at times so they
really need to take a look at whether
they've made the situation worse in
america by providing
inconsistent and wrong information to
the american public regularly
good point you know and a top issue for
parents everywhere this year in 2021 was
critical race theory being taught in our
schools but here's what the media wants
you to think about that
critical race theory is not being taught
in virginia public schools it's not
being taught in any public schools in
america because it's a legal scholarship
that is taught as an elected in law
school
kurt 15 seconds
uh critical race theory is not being
taught it's also essential that it be
taught
all at the same time again it's the
solution to every problem just lie
that's what the media does
hermet 15 seconds to you too as well my
friend
yeah absolutely critical race theory is
the latest label for a package of
propaganda including about gender and
transgender issues that's being
force-fed to our children it is
absolutely true it needs to come to an
end
well done thank you both and happy new
year hey sean hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to fox news youtube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else